kind of underwear do you wear
um boxer briefs boxer briefs yeah you're
very close you're very close to me and I
am not being weird I was just uh I I
would well see what kind of underwear do
you wear wouldn't you like to know
wouldn't you like to know I'm guessing
boxer briefs you'd be right do you know
what I really missed what tidy whities
on a man I love a tiny Whitey got a man
really are you being serious oh hell yes
tidy whities yes and nobody wears them
are and is anybody here wearing a tighty
whitey anybody raise your hand yeah
we're getting a couple people sir you
Joey this man is shaking his head I just
I I got to know I used to when I grew up
and no thanks anymore